il y a quelques jours un informaticien
de 23 ans décide de s'acheter un disque
dur externe mais en le connectant à son
ordinateur le jeune homme constate que
sont déjà enregistrés sur l'appareil des
lettres des pièces d'identité et de
nombreux documents personnels
appartenant à un octogénère j'ai vu les
dossier et je me suis dit e qu'est-ce
que c'est et parmi ces différents
fichiers l'homme de 23 ans découvre des
photos et des vidéos intimes de l'homme
de 80 ans qui apparaît tout nu quand
j'ai regardé les images j'ai été choqué
et si un enfant avait acheté ce disque
dur le jeuneomme qui dit scandalisé
dénonce un manque de protection de la
part de l'enseigne qui s'est de son côté
excusé auprès de
l'octogénère ah
ouais ils ont mis longtemps à savoir ce
qui s'était passé et en fait l'octogéère
a voulu faire réparer son ordinateur et
la ferme lui dit c'est impossible donc
il dit bah j'en rachète un œuf mais
éliminer ce qu'il y avait sur l'ancien
ordinateur et un gars de la société de
vente a pris le disque dur externe pour
purger l'ordinateur mais après il l'a
remis en en vente et c'est pour ça que
le jeune a acheté il a oublé surtout qu'
a 80 ans mais des newes sur un disque
dur question mais c'est vrai g 80 pr des
photos du AW pour ouf il peuv être bien
golé il y avait sa vie dessus quoi il
peuv être bien golé bah pourquoi pas 80
mais à 80 ans ça ça ça ça ah non sans
rigoler ça marche encore non non c'est
char parce que toi toi qui connais le B
bah ouais bien sûr quoi il est à 80 ans
bien sûr B chamerille avec Michel lerand
disait que c'était formidable il avait
plus de 80 ans non non arrête arrête non
non mais pourquoi il pren des baes
g con je peux pas donner de nom mais
système de
pouli vra système de de
pi c'est quoi ça les poir B les poir on
met comme un ballon à l'intérieur de la
l'air de bien conna avec une F poire on
gonfle comme ballon de boudruche
bieneas une
bouée c'est quoi
ba tu dis je peux pas donner de nom mais
des gens très très conn Mar trs bien
c'est qui la personne la plus
vieilleelle avait quel âge avec qui
tuitamour il avait 5 70 à peu près ah
ouais plusas pas fait plus plus plus
mais j'avais j'avais 20
25 30 ans à ce momentl donc donc
imaginons Polska avec quelqu'un de 70
ans tu es sûr que c'était bien c'était
pas sa
can non non ça ça marchait très très
bien non vraiment ah ouais non mais
c'est ouf ouis mais cétait fripé non euh
toi tu fais un sans fa ce soir s
déconner to ce soir c'est un truc de fou
non mais tu as
toujours s déconner tu tu réfléchis à ce
que tu dis ça sort de ta
bouche ça sort tout seul alors je
t'explique il a c'est ça qui est ouf
chez hommes tout vieillli sauf en fait
c'est un truc de ouf moi j'ai vu des
vieilles tub
excusez-moi à quelle occasion au salon
au salon la non non mais c'est une bonne
question bah au repos un peu mais après
on est vraiment oigé on fait vraiment
ças Témo même je n'en ai jamais vu des
jeunes donc je peux pas
comparer
JACC c'est pour toi retourne au marché
tu fais quoi
dimanche alors les chér on a tous parlé
de la robe table de Miss lor une robe
qui a beaucoup fait parler le créateur
de la robe s expliqu
regardez un corset en fait avec des
tiges en métal à l'intérieur ensuite on
a une surface solide en carton plume en
dessous qui fait vraiment toute la
circonférence de la table et par-dessus
donc nous avons cette robe qui est dans
un tissu d'amassé c'est un tissu qui est
un petit peu épais parce que je voulais
quelque chose qui fasse luxueux et de
bonne qualité pour représenter ce
restaurant un peu étoilé qu'on imagine
tous avec voilà ces belles nabes bien
repassé et bien blanc je me doutais bien
que ça allait interpeller mais de
suciter autant de méchanceté je pensais
pasit fracassé sur les réseaux sociaux
d'une manière telle qu'il est obligé de
sortir du silence les explications sont
pas très
convainquant surtout il a réussi son
coup une Rob gun snisme fou parce que
c'était ja
ou
je dis bravo gar d'ailleurs il a dit au
début j'ai j'ai même retouté parce que
je trouvais que c'était drôle au début
c'était plutôt bon enfant et après c'est
parti complètement su on a commencé à
m'insulter et cetera ENF insulter euh
les ché est-ce que vous cachez les
cadeaux de Noël avant de Oui Oui pour
les enfants ouais tu les mets où tout
mon
lit tout ton lit c'est pas c'est pas
évident c'est évident à trouver mais tu
les caches à qui en fait bah à ma maman
je fais tout jour à la maison m elle
voit pas s non non mais non mais elle
sait que je cher les de là-bas même les
tris là déconner entre
C je suis dans un 40 m Carr j'ai pas
trop trop de possibilité donc sous le
lit mais on cherche pas en fait
justement on sait qu'on les a caché tu
offire quoi tu vas offrir quoi à ta mère
euh bah chemise de nuit des trucs comme
ça parce elle a 92 ans donc pas lui
acheter une une barre de
PO c'est cohérent en même
tempsanger ça peut faire une animation
je suis désolé les gars je suis pas
complètement hosyle
tu Luas offert des chemises de nuit bah
ouais des choses comme ça une petite
robe de chambre nouvelle et tu fais Noël
avec qui bah avec ma maman que ta maman
bah ouais mais ça toujours depuis
toujours j'ai jamais fêé no ouais ah
ouais ça serait super parce qu'en plus
elle sait
pas elle sait plus que c'est Noël en
fait je vais passer je passer mais
pourquoi plutôt vous les accueillez pas
chez vous pour Noël parce qu'il y
auraêtre plus de monde sera plus festif
et comme ça sil passe il peut partir
quand il veut c'est plus sympatique
c'est
plus ça reste dormir ça reste
dormir je connais ça je vais voir sa
mère elle va essayer la chemise de nu va
se balader chez
moi mon frère je
t'expque c'est pas
halloween rabitoi c'est pas halloween
c'est Noël mais c'est l'esprit de Noëls
contente de vous voir je t'explique mais
char je sûr que ça vous ferait plaisir
en plus qui envie que je passe avec j'ai
rien prévu pour no qui envie envie
m'inviter pour Noël ah bah ouais venez
si vous voulez passer une tte bienven
bien sûr vraiment ah oui ah benah tu
viens pourquoi tuas un amour avec joie
moi aussi moi je suis à 800 km je pas
faire je suis à biit un chic Chac tu
crois quoi ah vous prenez votre jet vous
venez moi aussi je t'invite je suis à
600 km à peu près tu es où à côté
d'Arles entre Avignon et Arles tu vas tu
pars avec qui ouis bah ma femme et mes
enfants ah ouais ah oui et ou ça va làas
vuasu l' V le gars il a une femme et des
enfants il a
une qui
milardaard c'est un truc de ouf quoi
c'est un truc de malade quoi g tu
m'invites pas
non je suis toujours sincère j'ai pas
envie de vous voir Noël
oh la vraie question la vraie question
c'est est-ce que moi j'ai envie de te
voir non mais c'est envie de voir tout
le temps ça famille recomposée bah avec
tous les enfants et en tout ouais mais
je va pas venir tuas raison je va me
faire chier là des gamins là qui gueule
là pas que ça à [__] en plus il va
falloir que je fasse des cadeaux à ces
connards les
enfants non mais je te dire tu sais les
enfants sont comme les parents ils
prennent toujours la TR je dire je dire
le fr ne tombe jamais bien loin de
l'arbre Raymon Vernon dans le 27 c'est
moi le plus près je suis dans le 27 tu
viens il a tu viens il y a la cheminée
non mais c'est c'est bouché c'est plus
rapide d'aller dans le 27 que d'aller à
parisant je vais chez benim non arrête a
pas de cheminé là c'est une grande mais
Paris si vous avez rien de mieux à faire
j'habite près de Bin vous pouvez faire
bah ma famille
Daniel ma
mère Daniel le mien ah
d'accordcise parce que voilà et ma
famille on sera une une douzaine je
viens je viens si vous voulez vous
faites l'entrée chez Bena et faites le
paneton et chez moi ah parce que moi
j'ai pas le droit de
venir est-ce que vous m'invitez déjà qui
m'invite vous pouvez he vous c'est quoi
moi c'est en Pologne du coup
ah pas après vous avez quelques phrases
maintenant elle vous a je prendre la N
13 donc ouais c'est Pologne ouais c'est
à zlotu d'accord c'est quoi le programme
euh bah on mange polonais on parle
polonais on chante polonais ah ouais
bien c'est le meilleur des paysans des
paysans et si je parle polonis je fais
quoi je traduis d'accord comment dit
joyeux Noël en polonnais y a qui Bessa
chante Bessao chiante ça veut dire tu es
très
[Applaudissements]
chiante comm col polonais tu es très
chiante he c'est la même chose donc il y
a qui a toute votre famille oui vous
êtes combien beaucoup non vraiment des
Polonais qui arrivent de partout plein
de Polonais partout et donc moi je suis
au milieu je fais quoi là bah tu es là
service le service service azise tu peux
nous amener la bûche s'il te
plaît il vont voir arriver il vont dire
c'est qui cet asise aise la bûche là j
ch ils ont amené un il bouge pas il
bouge pas son cul la soirée c'est qui ce
gars là et toi Strasbourg capitale de
Noël
c'est moi qui fait à manger en plus non
tu es sale s tu es sale je mange pas
quelque chose que tu fais toi tu es sale
avoir des
excréments je connais deux chiens ou un
BA comme ça je connais il est sale il
est sale je l'ai vu j'ai vécu avec lui
ah on a vécu ensemble arrêtez tout un
été il était à la maison frère céit un
truc de ouf é oigé de fout de dire quoi
sale il est sale c'estes chiens sont
sales mais non ils sont propres chiens
ils ont chier dans la piscine connard
oui mais c'est une fois une fois
FO une FO TR é ballonné ah oui c'est
grave mais c'est horrible je me levais
le matin je vois un chien en train de
nager frère c'est un truc de
fouillon Mas desettes Deillon avec
des non mais je vous jure que c'est vra
mais c'est horrible non mais sans
déconner j'ai passé les pires vacances
de ma vie c'est pas de leur faute ils
étaient ballonnés ils avaient mangé doné
des fr éta ballonnés fais ch mais vous
savez que c'est un Noël important pour
Guillaume oui ouais c'est le Noël le
premier le dernier Noël sans ex venez en
plus je vais faire à manger et tout je
t'exlique je vous dis tout de suite ceux
qui sont éliminés toi tu es éliminé
pourquoi tu ça Gill il est éliminé parce
que de toute façon même s'il m'avait
invité c'est non Daniel j'ai j'ai encore
AC franchement on écoutera du André
Rieux un cauchemar car c'est mort non
non mais attends attends moi j'ai je
t'ai pas tout dit mais d'abord j'ai un
chat et une chatte ça évite d'avoir moi
aussi à ce
momentl aussi à ce moment par contre
j'ai pas de cheminée mais j'ai un poil à
granule ouais ouaisès sympa non mais
vous m'angoissez et puis j'ai une belle
piscine tu veux dire ça re
Géraldine ouis g ben rond bien entendu
Paul et Jean-Michel même les C je en
train de prendre au prier tour vous êtes
éliminé au premier tour le reste c'est
sû avec plaisir finalement éliminé
aussi
éliminé aussil c'est nouveau
mais en polne
ou tu le bourdon ma grand-mère va Chau
ma
grandmère allez les gars